The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
let's get started.
So today, we start out geometry,
geometric data structures.
There are two lectures on this.
This is lecture one.
And we're going to solve
two main problems today.
One is point location, which
is finding yourself on a map.
And the other is
orthogonal range searching,
which is catching a bunch of
dots with a rectangular net.
And they're fun problems.
And they're good illustrations
of a couple of techniques.
We're going to cover two general
techniques for data structure
building.
One is dynamizing
static data structures,
turning static into dynamic
using a technique called weight
balance, which is really cool.
And another one is called
fractional cascading,
which has probably one
of the coolest names
of any algorithmic or
data structures technique.
It's actually a very simple
idea, but sounds very scary.
And with point
location, we're going
to see some fun connections to
persistence and retroactivity,
which was the topic of the last
two lectures, you may recall.
And so we'll start
out with that.
Planar point location, you
can do it in higher dimensions
as well.
In general, geometric
data structures
are about going to more
than one dimension.
Most data structures are about
one dimensional ordered data.
Now, we have points
in the plane.
We might have
polygons in the plane.
So this is what we
call a planar map,
got a bunch of line
segments and points
forming a graph structure.
So think of it as a
planar graph drawn
in the plane where every edge
is a straight line segment.
And none of the edges
cross, let's say.
So this is a planar map.
It's also called a planar
straight line graph.
And the static version
of this problem--
so there's two versions,
one is static--
you want to preprocess the map.
So I give you a
single map up front.
And then I want to support
dynamic queries, which are
which face contains a point p.
So that point is
going to be given
to you as coordinates x and y.
So maybe I mark a
point like this one.
I give you those x
and y coordinates.
I want to quickly
determine that this face is
the one that contains it.
I give you another
point over here.
It quickly determines this face.
This has a lot of applications.
If you're writing a GUI and
someone clicks on the screen,
you need to map the coordinates
that the mouse gives you
to which GUI element
you're clicking on.
If you have a GPS
device and it has a map,
so it's preprocessed
the map all at once.
And now, given two GPS
coordinates, latitude,
longitude, it needs to
know which city you're in,
which part of the map you're
in, so that it knows what
to display, that sort of thing.
These are all planar
point location problems.
It comes up in simulation,
lots of things.
It's actually one of
the first problems
I got interested in
algorithms way back
in my oceanography days.
So that's planar point location.
That's the static version.
The dynamic version--
make things harder--
is the map is dynamic.
So here, the map is static.
The queries are
still coming online.
Dynamic version, you can insert
and delete edges in your map.
And let's say if you get
a vertex down to degree 0,
you can delete the vertex
as well, add new degrees
0 vertices.
As long as you
don't have crossings
introduced by inserting
edges, you can change things.
So that's obviously harder.
And we can solve this problem
using persistence and using
retroactivity in a pretty simple
way using a technique which you
may have seen before,
pretty classic technique
in computational geometry.
So this is a
technique that comes
from the algorithms world.
And we're going to apply it
to the data structures world.
So, sweep line technique,
it's a very simple idea.
So you have some line
segments in the plane,
something like this.
And I'm going to
take a vertical line.
So the algorithmic
problem is I want to know
are there any crossings.
Do any of these segments cross?
This is where sweep line
technique comes from,
I believe.
So the idea is we want to
linearize or one-dimensionalify
the problem.
So just take a slice of the
problem with a vertical line.
And imagine sweeping that
line from left to right.
So you imagine it
moving continuously.
Of course, in reality,
it moves discretely.
Let me unambiguate
this a little bit.
OK.
There are discrete
moments in time
when what is hit by
the sweep line changes.
Let me maybe label
these segments.
We've got a, b, c, and d.
So initially, we hit nothing.
Then we hit a, then we hit b.
Why do we hit b?
Because we saw the
left end point of b.
Then we see the right endpoint
of a which means we no longer--
sorry, at this point, we see
both a and b in that order.
Then we lose a, so
we're down to b.
Then we see c.
c is above b.
Then we see d. d
is above c and b.
Then c and d cross.
So c and d change positions.
And then we have b.
Then we lose b, then we lose c.
Then we lose d.
This is a classic algorithm for
detecting these intersections.
I don't want to get into
details how you do this.
But you're trying to look for
when things change in order
in these cross-sections.
The way you do that
is you maintain
the cross-section in
a binary search tree,
so you maintain the order.
If you hit a left endpoint, you
insert into the binary search
tree.
If you see a right endpoint, you
delete from the binary search
tree.
And you do some stuff
to check for crossings.
In this problem, there
are no crossings.
So we don't need to
worry about that.
But we're taking this technique.
Say, OK, there's a
data structure here,
which is the binary search tree
maintaining the cross-section.
OK.
So, typically, the
cross-section data structure
is regular balanced
binary search tree.
Our idea is what if
we add persistence
to that binary search tree?
So instead of using a
regular binary search tree,
we use a partially persistent
balanced binary search
tree, which we know how to do.
This is a bounded
n degree structure.
We can make it partially
persistent, constant overhead.
So if we add
partial persistence,
what does that let us do?
Well, let's just
look at a moment
in the past, partial persistence
about querying the past.
So there's a sequence of
insertions and deletions
that occur from the sweep line.
But now, if we can query
in the past, that's
like going to a desired
x-coordinate and saying,
what does my data structure
look like at this moment?
OK.
Now, the data structure,
let's maybe look at this one,
because it's got three
elements, very exciting.
So you've got d, then c, then b.
So you've got a
little data structure
that looks something like this.
It understands the order
of the cross-section
of those segments.
And so, for example, if
I was given a query point
like this one, I
could figure out
what is the segment above me,
what is the segment below me.
That is a successor query
and a predecessor query
in that binary search tree.
This notation maybe-- a query
at time t of, let's say,
successor of y is what we call
an upward ray shooting query
from coordinates t,y.
So t, the time, is
acting as x-coordinate.
Time is left to right here.
And so what's happening is we're
imagining, from this point,
shooting a ray upward
and asking what is
the segment that I hit first.
That's an upward
ray shooting query.
And this is from a problem
called vertical ray shooting,
which is more or less equivalent
to planar point location.
So vertical ray shooting, again,
you're given a map, planar map.
And the queries are like this.
What is the first segment that
you hit with an upward ray?
So I give you a point, x,y.
And I ask, if I
go up from there,
what's the next edge that I get?
That's the vertical
ray shooting problem.
And we just solved
the vertical ray
shooting problem for static.
If you're given a static map,
you run this algorithm once,
assume there are no crossings.
Then to answer vertical
ray shooting query,
we just go back
in time to time t,
do the successor query,
which takes log n time,
and then we get
the answer to this.
So we can do this in
log n per query static.
This is all two dimensional.
I should probably say that.
You can generalize.
Questions?
This is actually really easy.
This is the stuff we get
for free out of persistence
and, at the moment,
retroactivity.
I believe this is one of
the reasons persistence
was invented in the first place.
There were a bunch of early
persistent data structures.
Then there was a
general Driscoll paper,
which I talked about.
But I think geometry was
one of the main motivations.
Because it lets you
add a dimension.
As long as that dimension
is time-like, then
you get the dimension
sort of for free.
So that's nice.
OK.
What about retroactivity?
Again, we're going to use
partial retroactivity.
And I can tell you for
certainty, because I was there,
this is why retroactivity
was invented.
So retroactivity,
so that would mean
that we get to
dynamically add and delete
insertions and deletions.
So that's like adding
and deleting segments
from the structure.
Again, we have a
linear timeline.
We always want to maintain
a linear timeline,
because that is reality.
That corresponds to
the x-coordinate.
And now I want to be able to
add a segment like this, which
means there was an insertion
at this time, a deletion
at this time.
Now, this doesn't quite work.
Because this point
in cross-section,
it's actually moving over time.
Binary search trees, that's
OK, because things are simple.
But at the moment,
all we know how to do
is actually horizontal segments,
which are inserted and deleted
at the same y-coordinate.
So then we can do
insert at time t1,
an insertion of
some y-coordinate,
and then an insert
at some later time,
the deletion of
that y-coordinate.
So this is a partially
retroactive successor problem.
This is equal to dynamic
vertical ray shooting.
I guess this
insertion corresponds
to the insertion of a thing.
If you instead do
delete here, then you're
deleting one of the segments.
This is among
horizontal segments.
So if your map is made of
horizontal and vertical
segments--
so it's an orthogonal map--
then you can solve the dynamic
problem using a partially
retroactive successor.
Again, we want to do
successor just like before,
querying the past.
But now, our updates
are different.
Now, we have
retroactive updates.
That lets us dynamically
change the past,
which is like inserting
and deleting edges
through that algorithm.
But at the moment,
we only know how
to do this for
horizontal segments.
So this gives us,
if you remember,
the retroactive
successor result.
We haven't seen
that, how it works.
It's complicated.
But it achieves log n insert,
delete successor retroactively.
And so we get a log n,
which is an optimal solution
for dynamic vertical
ray shooting
among horizontal segments.
There are a bunch
of open problems.
What about general maps?
So for a dynamic vertical
ray shooting in general maps,
if you want log n
query, the best results
are log to the 1 plus
epsilon insert log
to the 2 plus epsilon delete.
There's some other trade-offs.
You can get log times log
log n query and reduce.
Still, we don't know
how to delete faster
than log squared in any
of the general solutions.
So you can do log
square for everything.
But the hope would be you could
do log for everything even when
the segments are not horizontal.
But here, retroactivity
doesn't seem to buy you things.
It'd be nice if you could.
Another fun open
problem is, what
about non-vertical rays,
general rays, non-vertical rays?
So I give you a point
and I give you a vector,
I want to know what do
I hit in that direction.
This is a lot harder.
You can't use any
of these tricks.
And in fact, it's believed you
cannot get polylog performance
unless you have a ton of space.
So the best known result is--
I'll just throw this up here.
You can get n over square
root s polylog and query.
If you use, basically, s space.
So you need quite
a bit of space.
Because if you use n to
the 1 plus epsilon space,
you can get roughly
root n query time.
If you use n to
5 space, then you
get somewhat better query
time, but still not great.
You can maybe get down
to n to the epsilon
if you have very large
polynomial space.
But this is conjectured
to be roughly optimal,
I assume, other than
the polylog factors.
The belief is you cannot
beat this for general ray.
This is kind of
annoying, because this
is a problem we care about.
Especially in 3D,
this is ray tracing.
You shoot a ray,
what does it hit?
You bounce it.
You shoot another ray.
I always want to know
what objects am I hitting.
And for special cases,
you can do better.
But in general, it
seems quite hard.
This is even in two dimensions.
But there are a bunch of
papers on 3D and so on.
I just wanted to give you those
connections to persistence
and retroactivity.
And that's point location.
And now, I want to go on two
orthogonal range searching.
We can do some new data
structures, new to us.
So first, what is the problem?
So it's sort of the reverse
kind of problem here.
You're given a bunch of points
before the query was a point.
And the query, in
this case, is going
to be, in two dimensions,
a rectangle, a window
if you will.
And you want to know what
points are in the rectangle.
So given n points and d
dimensions, query in general
is going to be a box.
So in 2D, it's an interval
crossing interval.
In 3D, it's three intervals
cross-product together.
OK.
So in the static version, you
get to preprocess the points.
In the dynamic
version, the points
are being added and deleted.
And in all cases, we
have dynamic queries,
which are what are
the points in the box.
Now, there are different
versions of this query.
There is an existence
query, which is are there
any points in the box?
That's sort of the easiest.
Next level up is, how many
points are in the box?
Which you can use
to solve existence.
Next level up is give me
all the points in the box,
or give me 10 points in the
box, give me a point in the box.
All of these problems are
more or less the same.
They do differ in some cases.
But the things
we'll see today, you
can solve them all
about as efficiently.
But, of course, if you want to
list all the points in the box,
it could be everything.
And so that could
take linear time.
So in general, our goal is to
get a running time something
like log n plus k, where k
is the size of the output.
So if you're asking how
many points are in there,
the size the output
is a single number.
So k is 1, you should
get log n time.
If you want to list 100
points in there, k is 100.
And so you have to
pay that to list them.
If you want to know all
of them, well, then k
is the number of points
that are in there.
And we'll be able to achieve
these kinds of bounds
pretty much all the time,
definitely in two dimensions.
In D dimensions, it's
going to get harder.
OK.
So I want to start out
with one dimension just
to make sure we're
on the same page.
And in general, we're going to
start with a solution called
range trees, which were
simultaneously invented
by a lot of people in the
late '70s, Bentley, one
of the main guys.
And in general, we're going to
aim here for a log to the d n
plus k query time.
So I like this, but now we
have a dependence on dimension.
And for 2D, this is not great.
It's log squared.
And we're going to do better.
OK.
But let's start with d equals 1.
How do you do this?
How do I achieve
log n plus k query?
Sort the points.
Yeah.
I could sort the points,
then do binary search.
So the query now is
just an interval.
That's the one dimensional
version of a box.
So if I search for a, search
for b in a sorted list,
then all the points
in between I can
count the different indices--
or subtract the two
indices into the array.
That will give me how
many points there are
in the box, all these things.
Arrays aren't going to
generalize super nicely.
Although, we'll come
back to arrays later.
For now, I'd like to think
of a binary search tree,
balanced binary search tree.
And I'm going to make
it a little different
from the usual kind
of binary search tree.
I want the data to
be in the leaves.
So I want the leaves
to be my points.
And this will be convenient
for higher dimensions.
It doesn't really matter
for one dimension,
but it's kind of
nice to think about.
So you've got a
binary search tree.
And then here is the data sorted
by the only coordinate that
exists, the x-coordinate.
And so, of course,
I can search for a,
here's a maybe, search for b.
And the stuff in between
here, that is my result.
And in a little more detail,
as you search for a and b,
at some point,
they will diverge.
One will go left,
one will go right.
At some point, you reach a.
Maybe a isn't actually
in the structure.
You're searching for everything
between a and b inclusive,
but a may not be there.
So in general, we're going
to find the predecessor
and successor of a.
In this case, I'm interested
in the predecessor.
And similarly over
here, eventually--
this is all, of course,
logarithmic time--
I find the successor of b.
Those are the two things
I'm interested in.
And now, all the
leaves in between here,
that's the result. Question?
AUDIENCE: So if you have
the data just on the leaves,
what do you have
intermediate node?
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah, right.
So in the intermediate
nodes, I need to know,
let's say, if every subtree
knows the min and max, then
at a node, I can decide should
I go left, should I go right?
I think every node can store
the max of the left subtree
if you just want
one key per node.
But, yeah, good question.
Sorry, I forgot to mention that.
You store a representative
sort of in the middle
that lets you decide
whether to go left or right.
So you can still do searches.
We can find these two nodes.
And now, the answer is
basically all of this stuff.
I did not leave
myself enough space.
That's the left child.
OK.
So wherever this
left branch went
left, the right
branches in the answer.
Whenever this right
branch went right,
the left branch is the answer.
But from here, there's no
subtree that we care about.
Because this is all greater
than what we care about.
OK.
But the good news
is there's only
log n of these subtrees,
maybe two log n.
Because there's the left
side, the right side.
OK.
So the answer is
implicitly represented.
We don't have to explicitly
touch all these items.
We just know that they
live in the subtrees,
in those order log n subtrees.
So in particular, if every node
stores the size of its subtree,
then we can add up
these log n numbers.
And we get the
size of the answer.
If we want the first k items,
we can visit the first k items
here in order k time.
So in log n time, we get a nice
representation of the answers,
log n subtrees.
Of course, we also had a nice
answer when we had an array.
But this one will be
easier to generalize.
And that's range trees.
So that was a 1D range tree.
The only difference is we
put data at the leaves.
2D range tree has a simple idea.
We have the data
in these subtrees.
These are the matches.
Let's think we have
an x-coordinate
and a y-coordinate.
We have an x range
and a y range.
Let's do this for x.
Now, we have a representation
of all the matches in x.
So we want this rectangle.
But we can get this
entire slab in log n time,
and we have log n
subtrees that we now
have to filter in terms of y.
There's all these points out
here that we don't care about.
We want to get rid of those and
just focus in on these points.
So we're going to do
the same thing on y,
but we want to do
that for this subtree.
And we want to do
it for this subtree,
and for this subtree,
so simple idea.
For each subtree, let's
call it an x subtree.
So we have one tree which
represents all the x data.
It looks just like this.
And then for each
subtree of that x tree,
we store, let's say,
a pointer to a y tree,
which is also a 1D range tree.
So this guy has a pointer to
a similarly sized triangle.
Except, this one is on y.
This one's sorted by x.
This one's sorted
by y, same points.
This subtree also has one,
same data as over here,
but now sorted an
y instead of x.
For example, there is a
smaller tree inside this one.
That one also has a pointer
to a smaller y tree.
Except, now, these
are disjoined,
because these are completely--
yeah.
This is a subset of that one.
But we're going to store a y
tree for this one and a y tree
for this one.
So we're blowing up space.
Every element, every point
lives in log n y trees.
Because if you look
at a point, there's
the tiny y tree that contains
it bigger, bigger, bigger,
bigger until the entire
tree also contains it.
Each of those has a
corresponding y tree.
So the overall space
will be n log n.
We're repeating points here.
But the good news is now I can
do search really efficiently,
well, log squared efficiently.
I spend log time to find
these x trees that represent
the slabs that I care about.
So it's more like this picture.
So there's a bunch of
disjoint slabs, which together
contain my points in x.
And now I want to filter
each of them by y.
So for each of them, I
jump over to y space and do
a range query in y space just
like what we were doing here.
So search for a, search
for b, but in y-coordinate.
And then I get log n subtrees
in here, log n subtrees in here,
log n subtrees in here.
So the query gives me
log squared y subtrees.
It takes me log squared
n time to find them.
If I have subtree sizes, I
compute the number of matches
in log squared n time.
If I want k items, I
can grab k items out
of them in order k time.
OK.
Pretty easy.
Of course, D dimensions
is just the same trick.
You have x tree.
Every subtree links to a y tree.
Every y subtree
links to a z tree.
Every z subtree links
to a w tree, and so on.
For D dimensions, you're going
to get log to the D query
as I claimed before.
How much space?
Well, every dimension you
add adds another log factor
of space.
So it's going to be n log
to the d minus 1 space.
And if you want to
do this statically,
you can also build the
data structure in n log
to the d minus 1 n time,
except for d equals 1 where
you need n log n time to sort.
But as long as d
is bigger than 1,
this is the right bound
for higher dimensions.
It takes a little bit of
effort to actually build
the structure in that much
time, but it can be done.
OK.
That's the very
simple data structure.
Any questions about that
before we make it cooler?
You may have seen this
data structure before.
It's kind of classic.
But you can do
much better, well,
at least a log factor better.
AUDIENCE: Question.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when your storing
one pointer for each subtree,
you essentially have a
pointer for each root,
like for each node?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Right.
Every node.
So I know these are the nodes
that the stuff below them
represents my answer in x.
And so I teleport over to the
y universe from the x universe.
AUDIENCE: So, basically,
it has all the same nodes
of that subtree, but [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
All the points that
are in here also
live in here, except these
ones are sorted by x.
These ones are sorted by y.
If I kept following pointers,
I get to z and w and so on.
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if we were
doing the dynamic case,
how would we implement
rotations in the [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: OK.
Dynamic is annoying.
Yeah.
Rotations are annoying.
I think we'll come back to that.
We can solve that.
I thought it was easy,
but you're right.
Rotations are kind of annoying.
And we can solve that using
this dynamization trick.
So we don't have to worry
about it till we get there.
It's going to get even harder
to make things dynamic.
And so then we really need
to pull out the black box.
Well, it's not a black box.
We're going to see how it works.
But it's a general
transformation
that makes things dynamic.
OK.
Before we get a dynamic,
stick with static.
And let's improve
things by a log factor.
This is an idea called
layered range trees.
It's also sometimes called
fractional cascading,
which is the technique
we're going to get to later.
I would say it involves one
half of fractional cascading.
Fractional cascading
has two ideas.
And the one that it's named
after is not this idea.
So idea one is basically
to reuse searches.
The idea is we're
searching in this subtree
or, I guess, this subtree
with respect to y.
We're also searching for
the same interval of y
in this subtree.
Completely different
elements, but
if there was some way we
could reuse the searches for y
in all of these log n subtrees,
we could save a log factor.
And it turns out we can.
And this is one idea in
fractional cascading,
but there will be
another one later.
OK.
So, fun stuff.
This is where I want
to change my notes.
So we're searching in x with
a regular 1D range tree.
I also want to have a
regular 1D range tree--
range tree?
Sure.
Actually, it doesn't
matter too much.
I want to have an array
of all the items sorted
by y-coordinate.
And we're going to
simplify things here.
Instead of pointing
to a tree, I'm
going to point to an
array sorted by y.
This is totally static.
And this is where
dynamic gets harder,
not that know how to
do it over there yet.
So for each x
subtree, we're going
to have a pointer to the
same elements sorted by y.
So all the leaves
that are down here
are, basically, also there, but
by y coordinate instead of x.
Obviously, we can
still do the same thing
we could do before, spend
log n time to search
in each of these log n arrays
corresponding to these log n
subtrees.
And in log squared n,
we'll have our answers.
But we can do better now.
I only want to do one
binary search in y.
And that will be at the root.
So the root, there's
an array representing
everything sorted by y.
I search for the
lower y-coordinate.
I search for the upper
y-coordinate, some things.
It's hard to draw
this, because it's
in the dimensional
orthogonal to this one.
I guess I should really
draw the arrays like this.
So this guy has an array.
We find the upper
and lower bounds
for the y-coordinate
in the global space.
This takes log n time
to do two searches.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Those are the
upper and lower bounds
from the predecessor [INAUDIBLE]
successor [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, right.
So we're doing a predecessor
and successor search, let's say,
in this array.
Binary search we find--
I didn't give them
names, but in the notes
they're a1 through b1 and x.
And they're a2 through b2 and y.
So that's my query,
this rectangle.
I'm doing the search for a2
and for b2 in the top array.
Now, what I'd like to do
is keep that information
as I walk down the tree.
So that in the end, when
I get to these nodes,
I know where I am in
those arrays in y.
So let's think of that
just step by step.
So imagine in the x
tree, I'm at some node.
And then I follow, let's
say, a right pointer
to the right child.
OK.
Now, in y space--
maybe I should switch
to red for y space.
This guy has a really big array
representing all of the nodes
down here, but sorted
by y-coordinate.
This guy has a
corresponding array
with some subset of the nodes.
Which subset?
The ones that are to the
right of this x-coordinate.
So there's no relation.
I mean, some of the
guys that are here--
let me circle them--
some of these guys
exist over here.
They'll be in the
same relative order.
So here's those four
guys, then one, and two.
So some of these guys will
be preserved over here.
Some of them won't, because
their x-coordinate smaller.
It's an arbitrary subset.
These guys will also live here.
OK.
The idea is store pointers from
every element over here to,
let's say, the
successor over here.
So store these red arrows.
let's say, these guys
all point to this node.
These guys point to that node.
I guess these guys just
point to some adjacent node,
either the predecessor
or the successor.
So the result is if I know where
a2 and b2 live in this array,
I can figure out where
they live in this array.
I just follow the pointer.
Easy.
Done.
OK.
Let's think about
what this means.
So I'm going to store
pointers from the y
array of some x node.
Let's call that
node v in the x tree
to the corresponding places,
corresponding points,
let's say, in the y
arrays of left child of v
and the right child of v.
So, actually,
every array item is
going to have two
pointers, one if you're
going right in the x
tree, one if you're
going the left in the x tree.
But we can afford a constant
number of pointers per node.
This only increases space
by a constant factor.
And now, it tells me
exactly what I need to know.
I start at the root.
I do a binary search.
That's the slow part.
I spend log n time,
find those two slots.
Every time I go down,
I follow the pointer.
I know exactly where a2 and
b2 live in the next array.
In constant time, as I walk
down, I can figure this out.
I can remember the information
on both sides here.
And every time I go to
one of these subtrees,
I know exactly where I live--
it's no longer a tree--
now, in that array.
So I can identify the
regions in these arrays.
that correspond to these
matching subrectangles
with no extra time.
So I save that last log factor.
If you generalize
this to D dimensions,
it only works in
the last dimension.
You can use this trick
in the last dimension
and improve from log to the d
query to log to the d minus 1.
In the higher dimensions, we
just use regular range trees.
And when we get down to
the two dimensional case,
it's a recursion.
Before we were stopping at
the one dimensional case.
We use a regular
binary search tree.
Now, we stop at the
two dimensional case,
and we use this fancy thing.
I call this cross-linking.
A lot of people call it
fractional cascading.
Both are valid names.
It's a cool idea,
but simple once you
can see both dimensions
at once, which I know it's
hard to see in two dimensions.
But it can be done.
All right.
Questions?
I guess the obvious
question is dynamic.
Now, we're going
to go to dynamic.
This is a very static
thing to be doing.
How in the world
would we maintain this
if the point set is changing?
All these pointers are
going to move around.
Life seems so hard.
But it's not.
In fact, updates are a lot
easier than you might think.
Some of you may believe
this in your heart.
Some of you may not.
But if you've ever seen an
amortization argument that
says, basically, when
you modify a tree,
only a constant number
of things happen.
And they usually
happen near the leaves.
I'm thinking of a
binary search tree.
The easiest way to see
this is in a B-tree
if you know B-trees.
Usually, if you do
insertion, you're
going to do maybe one or
two splits at the bottom,
and that's it.
Constant fraction at a
time, that's all there is.
So it should only take
constant time to do an update.
This structure is easy
to update at the leaves.
If you look at one of these
structures, a constant number
of items, there's a
constant size array.
You could update everything
in constant time.
If we're only up to hitting near
the leaves, then life is good.
Occasionally,
though, we're going
to have to update
these giant structures.
And then we're going to
have to spend giant time.
That's OK.
The only thing we need
out of this data structure
is that it takes the same amount
of space and pre-processing
time, n log to d minus 1
space, and time to build
the static data structure.
If we have this, it turns out
we can make it dynamic for free.
This is the magic of
weight balance trees.
In general, there are many
kinds of weight balance trees.
We're going to look
at one called BB alpha
trees, which are the oldest
and sort of the simplest.
Well, you'll see.
It's pretty easy to do.
You've already seen
height balance trees.
AVL trees, for example, you keep
the left and the right subtree.
You want their height to be
within an additive constant
of each other, 1.
Red black trees are
multiplicative factor 2.
Left and right
subtree, the heights
will be roughly the same.
Weight balance trees,
weight is the number
of nodes in a subtree.
Weight balance trees,
they want to keep
the size of the left subtree and
the size of the right subtree
to be roughly the same.
So here's the definition
of BB alpha trees.
For each node v, size
of the left subtree of v
is at least alpha
times the size of v.
And size of the
right subtree of v
is at least alpha times
the size of v. Now, size,
I didn't define size.
It could be the total number
of nodes in the subtree.
It could be the number
of leaves in the subtree.
Doesn't really matter.
What else?
What's alpha?
Alpha is a half,
you're in trouble.
Because then it has to
be perfectly balanced.
But just make alpha small,
like 1/10 or something.
Any constant less
than a half will do.
Right.
The nice thing
about weight balance
is they imply height balance.
If you have this property
that neither your left
nor your right subtree are too
small, then as you go down,
every time you take a
left or a right child,
you throw away an alpha
fraction of your nodes.
So initially, you
have all the nodes.
Every time you go down,
you lose an alpha fraction.
How many times can that happen?
Log base alpha, basically,
so log base 1 over alpha.
The height is log base
1 over alpha of n.
So this is really a stronger
property than height balance.
It implies that your
heights are good.
So it implies the height of
the left and right subtree
are not too far from each other.
But it's a lot stronger.
It lets you do updates
lickety fast, basically.
So how do we do an update?
The idea is, normally,
you insert a leaf,
do a regular BST,
insert a delete.
You add a leaf at the
bottom or delete a leaf.
And so you have to update like
that node and maybe its parent.
As long as you have
weight balance,
you're just making little
constant sized changes
at the bottom.
Everything's good.
OK.
The trouble is when one of these
constraints becomes violated.
Then you want to do a
rotation or something.
OK.
So when a node is
not weight balanced,
it's a pretty loose algorithm.
But it's easy to find nodes.
You just store all the
weights, all the subtree sizes,
which we were doing already.
You can detect when nodes are
no longer weight balanced.
And then we just want
to weight balance it.
How do we weight balance it?
We rebuild the entire
subtree from scratch.
This is sort of the only
thing we know how to do.
We have a static data structure.
This is a general
transformation, dynamization
when you have augmentation.
We have this data structure.
It's got all these
augmented things.
It's complicated.
But at least it's sort
of downward looking.
I mean, you only need to
store pointers from here down,
not up.
I mean, your parent
points into you.
But you have a nice local thing.
So if this guy's
not weight balanced,
if this left subtree is way
heavier than the right subtree
by this alpha factor,
one over alpha factor,
then just redo
everything in here.
Find the median.
Make a perfect
binary search tree.
Then the weights between
the left and the right
will be perfectly balanced.
We'll have achieved the one
half, one half split of weight.
How long before it
gets unbalanced again?
A long time.
If I start with a one half,
one half split, and then
I have to get to an alpha
1 minus alpha split,
a lot of nodes had to move
from one side to the other.
The alpha gets messy.
So let me just say
when this happens,
rebuild entire subtree.
I guess it's like a 1/2
minus alpha had to move.
1/2 minus alpha times
the size of the subtree
had to be inserted or deleted,
had to happen, or maybe half
of that, some constant fraction.
I don't really care.
Alpha's a constant.
I'm going to charge
to the theta k
updates that unbalance things.
k here is the size
of the subtree.
k So when I see a node is
on balance, just fix it.
Make it perfect.
And if I started out perfect,
the subtree started out
perfect, I know there were theta
k updates that I can charge to.
The only catch is I'm actually
double charging quite a bit,
actually.
If you look at a tree,
if I do an insert here,
it makes this subtree
potentially slightly
unbalanced.
It makes this subtrees
slightly unbalanced.
It makes this subtree
There are log n subtrees
that contain that item.
Each of them may
be getting worse.
So if I say, well, yeah, there
are these theta k updates,
but actually there are log
n different subtrees that
will charge to the same update.
So I lose a log n factor
in this amortization.
But it's not so bad.
I get log n amortized update.
This is if a rebuild
costs linear time.
This is pretty nifty.
I don't have to do
rotations per se.
I just take all the notes in
the subtree, write them down.
I do an in order traverse.
I have them sorted,
take the median,
build a nice perfect binary
search tree on those items.
I can easily do
that in linear time.
And so this is like
the brain dead way
to make this weight
balanced tree dynamic.
The original BB alpha
trees use rotations.
But you don't have to.
You can do this very simple
thing and still get a log n
amortized update.
And the good news is, if you
have augmentation as well--
because with this
subtree, there's
tons of extra stuff, all these
arrays and pointers and stuff,
it's easy to build from scratch.
But it's hard to
maintain dynamically.
The point is, now,
we don't have to.
If ever we need
to change a node,
we just rebuild
the entire subtree.
And we can afford it at the
loss of a logarithmic overhead.
So we had n log to the d minus
1 n time to build the structure.
So for a structure
of size k, it's
going to be k times log
to the d minus 1 of k.
We're going to lose
an extra log factor.
So this d minus 1 is going
to turn into a d minus 2
for updates.
So that was the
generic structure.
And now, if we apply this
to layered range trees,
we get log to the d
n amortized update.
Because we had k
times log to the d
minus 1 of k pre-processing
to rebuild node.
And just to recall,
we still have log
to the d minus 1 of n query.
So this was regular range trees.
And we've made them dynamic,
the same time as range trees.
And still, the query
is a log factor faster.
So for 2D, we get log n query
log squired n update insertion
and deletion of points.
Questions about that?
Cool.
Well, that is range searching,
orthogonal range searching.
Let's see.
There are more
results, which I don't
want to cover in detail here.
But you should at
least know about them.
And then we're going to
turn to fractional cascading
a little more generally.
So where is this result?
Somewhere here.
So for static orthogonal
range searching,
range searching is a big area.
We're looking at
the orthogonal case.
There's other versions
where you're querying
with a triangle or a simplex.
You can query with
two-sided box, which
goes out to infinity here.
All sorts of things
are out there.
But let me stick to rectangles.
Because that's what we've
seen and we can relate to.
You can achieve
these same bounds--
sorry, no update.
You can achieve the
log to the d minus 1
n query using less space.
So I can get log
to the d minus 1 n
query and n log to the
d minus 1 n space--
that's what we were
getting before--
divided by log log n.
Slight improvement.
And in a certain model,
this is basically optimal,
which is kind of even crazier.
This is an old
result by Chazelle.
That's in '86.
OK.
This is 2D-- sorry, not
2D, just in general.
Turns out this query
time is not optimal.
If you allow the space
to go up a little bit,
you can get another
log improvement.
So I can get log
to the d minus 2
and query if I'm
willing to pay--
I didn't this is space--
n log to the d n space.
So if I give up another
log factor in space,
I can get another
log factor in query.
I don't think you
can keep doing that.
But for one more step, you can.
I believe this is conjectured
optimal for query.
I don't know if it's proved.
And this was originally
done by Chazelle and Guibas
using fractional cascading.
And we'll see.
If there's time next class,
I'll show you how this works.
But for now, I want
to tell you in general
how fractional cascading
works in generality.
This is part of
fractional cascading,
this idea of cross-linking from
a bigger structure to a smaller
one, so that you don't
have to keep researching.
You just reuse where you were.
But there's another idea.
I want to show you that idea.
So, fractional cascading.
AUDIENCE: Would that
work for d equals 2?
ERIK DEMAINE: For d equals
2, no it does not work.
So I should say this
is for 2D and higher.
D has to be bigger than 1.
Because you can never be log n.
So for 2D and higher, we could
use the trick that we just did.
For 3D and higher, you can
improve by another long,
thanks.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: But you said
you can never beat log n.
ERIK DEMAINE: We can
never beat log n.
In this model, which is
basically comparison model,
we're comparing coordinates.
In that model and
many other models,
you can't beat log n query.
Because in particular, you have
to solve the search problem
in 1D.
So we're always
hampered by that.
But the question is,
how does it grow with d?
And the claim is we can get
log n all the way up to three
dimensions.
Only at four dimensions do
we have to pay log squared.
It's pretty amazing I think.
OK.
Fractional cascading-- super
cool name, kind of scary name.
I was always scared when I heard
about fractional cascading.
But it turns out,
it's very simple.
Goal today is to not be scared.
Let's start with
a warm up problem.
And then I'll tell you
its full generality.
But simple version
of the problem
is not geometry, per se.
It's kind of 1 and 1/2
dimensions, if you will.
Suppose I have k lists
and each has size n.
They're sorted
lists, think of them.
So we have n items come
from an ordered universe.
Here's list one.
Here's list two.
Here's a list three.
There's k of them.
Each of them has n items.
I would like to
search the query.
We'll just do static here.
Original fractional
cascading was just static.
And these results
are just static.
You can make it dynamic,
but there is some overhead.
And I don't want
to get into that.
It's even messier,
or it is messy.
Fractional cascading by
itself is a very simple idea.
Query is search
for x in all lists.
OK.
So I want to know what is the
predecessor and successor of x
in this list.
I want to know what
is the predecessor
and successor in this list.
I want to know what's the
predecessor and successor
in this list, all of them.
It's more information.
If I just merged the
lists and searched for x,
I would find where
x fits globally.
But I want to know how it
fits relative to this list
and relative to this list
and relative to this list.
How do I do it?
I could just do k
binary searches.
So this is an easy
problem to solve.
You get k times log n.
But, now, fractional
cascading comes in.
And we can get the optimal
bound, which is k plus log n.
I need k to write
down the answers.
I need log n to do the
search in one list.
It turns out I can
search on all k lists,
simultaneously get all k
answers in k plus log n time.
It's kind of cool and,
actually, quite easy to do.
We want to use this concept.
If I could search for
my item, for x, in here,
and then basically follow
a pointer to where I want
to go in here, I'd be done.
Sadly, that can't be done.
Why?
Because who knows what
elements are in here?
All of these elements could
fit right in this slot.
And so how do I know where
to go in this giant list?
If these all fit in
here and, recursively,
these all fit in here,
then by searching up here,
I learn nothing about
where x fits in here.
I have to do another search.
And then I learn nothing
about where x fits in here.
So it doesn't work straight up.
But if we combine this idea
with fractional cascading,
then we can do it.
So I can erase this now.
So what do we do?
Idea is very simple.
So I'm going to call these
lists L1, L2, L3 up to Lk.
I want to add every other
item in Lk to Lk minus 1
and produce a new
list Lk minus 1 prime.
So I take every
second item here,
just insert them into this list.
[INAUDIBLE] it's a
constant fraction bigger.
And then repeat.
This is the fractional part.
Here, a fraction is one half.
You can make it
whatever fraction you
like less than one.
In general, I'm going to
add every other item--
this is in sorted order
in Lk, of course--
that's in Li prime--
the prime is the
important part here--
to Li minus 1 to
form Li minus prime.
So I've got this new
larger version of L2.
I take half the items from here.
Some of them may be
items that were in L3.
Some of them are items
that were originally in L2.
But all of them get promoted.
Or half of them
get promoted to L1.
So I keep promoting
from the bottom up.
How big do my lists get?
What is the size of Li prime?
Well, it started with Li.
And then I added
half of the items
that were in the next
level down, Li plus 1.
OK.
So this is n.
And so this is going
to be half of n
plus half of another
n plus half of--
I mean, it's going to be n
plus a half n plus a quarter n
plus an eighth n.
It's a geometric series.
This is just a
constant factor growth.
I'm assuming all the lists
have the same size here
for simplicity.
You can generalize.
So I didn't really make the
lists any bigger, per se.
But I fixed this problem.
If all of the elements in
L2 fit right here in L1,
it's no longer a problem.
Because, now, half of the
items from L2 now live in L1.
So when I search among
L1, I'm not quite
doing a global search.
But I'm finding
where I fit in L1.
I didn't contaminate
it too much from L2.
And then now, it's useful to
have pointers from L1 to L2.
Let me draw a picture maybe.
So here's L1, L2, L3.
So half of the items here
have been inserted into here.
Now, we don't really know--
maybe many of them went
near the same location.
But they went there.
And I'm going to have
pointers in both directions.
Let's say I need them down.
So that if I search in
here, I can figure out
where I am down here.
Then half of these guys--
maybe I'll use another color--
get promoted to
the next level up.
So maybe this one gets promoted.
Maybe this one gets promoted.
I guess half would be that one,
that one, that one, that one,
that one.
These guys get promoted
to the next level.
OK.
I claim this is
enough information.
This is fractional cascading
in its full generality.
We have the
cross-linking that we
had in the layered range trees.
But, now, we also have the
fractional cascading part,
which is you take a
fraction, you cascade it
into the next layer.
The cascading refers to those
guys continue to get promoted.
Half of them get
promoted up recursively.
That's where the
name comes from.
So now, how do we do a search?
We're going to start at the top.
And we're going to do a regular
binary search at the top.
Because we can
afford log n once.
So we do the binary
search at the top.
So maybe we find that our
item fits here in this search.
So that tells us,
oh, well, this is
where item x fits in this list.
Great.
Now, I need to
know where it fits
in the next list
in constant time.
Well, I need some more
pointers for this.
So for each item
in here, I'm going
to store a pointer to the
previous and next, let's say,
red node, the
previous and next node
that was promoted
from the list below.
OK.
So, now, I basically
know where it fits here.
Not quite, because this
is only half the items.
So I know that it fits
between this guy and this guy
in list 2 prime, technically.
So the only thing I don't
know is, is it here or here?
So I compare with this one item.
And in general, if
it's not a half,
if the fraction is
some other constant,
I spend constant time to look
at a constant number of items,
figure out where it
fits among those items.
Now, I know where
it fits in L2 prime.
Then I, again, follow
pointers to the next items.
In this case, they're
the white items.
So let's say it fits
here, basically.
I have a pointer to the
previous and next white item
from that item.
Follow those pointers down.
And now, I know it's either,
basically, here, here, here.
It's somewhere in that little
range of either equaling this
or being between these
two items or on this item
or between those two
items or on this item.
And, again, constant number
of things to look at.
I figure out where I belong.
In the primed list, which is
not quite the original list,
maybe I determine
that x falls here.
And what I really
want to know is
it's between this item and
that item of the original list.
I don't care so much
about the promoted lists.
So I need more
pointers, which tell me
if it happens that I fall here,
basically, every promoted item
has a pointer to the
previous and next unpromoted
item from the original list.
This is static.
I can have all these pointers.
Let's write them down.
So every promoted
item in Li prime--
that means it came from
a promotion from below--
has a pointer to the previous
and next non-promoted item.
So that's an item in Li.
OK.
That's two pointers.
And that's what we just use.
So I found where I was
among the entire L1
prime, which was almost like
a global search, not quite.
And then I follow these
points to figure out where
it was in the original L1.
Well, so if I found
that I was in the middle
of this big white region, I need
to find the next red region.
So it's basically the reverse.
Every non-promoted item, every
item in Li, has a pointer.
So this is basically Li
prime minus Li, if you will.
And then these
guys need a pointer
to the next and previous
in that, so previous
and the next item in
Li prime minus Li.
So these are the promoted items.
These are the unpromoted items.
So it's actually just
two pointers per item.
If you're promoted, you
store the previous and next.
Unpromoted, if
you're unpromoted,
you store the previous
and next promoted.
It's nice and symmetric.
It's pretty clean,
a lot of pointers,
hard to draw, but quite
simple in the end.
There's two main ideas.
One is to promote
recursively up,
just a constant fraction, so
the lists don't get much bigger.
Because it's a
constant fraction,
the gaps when you walk
down are constant size.
And so you basically
get free relocalization
within each list with
the help of some pointers
to walk down and jump left and
right between the two colors.
OK.
That's basic
fractional cascading
in that we solved this problem,
searched within k lists
each of size n and k plus log n
time, which is kind of amazing
I think, pretty cool.
But there's a more
general form of this,
uses the exact same ideas.
But I just want to tell you
how they generalized it.
This is Chazelle and Guibas.
So in general,
fractional cascading,
if you look at what
cascading is happening here--
here being here-- we essentially
have a path of cascades.
We start at the bottom and
push into the predecessor
in the path.
We push into the
predecessor in the path.
In the general case, we
do it on a graph instead
of a path, arbitrary graph.
So we have a graph.
The input, in some
sense, you can think
of this as a transformation.
But it's for a specific
kind of data structure.
The data structure is
represented by a graph.
And each vertex of the
graph has a set of elements
or a list of elements.
That's what we had here.
We had a path here.
And each node in the path had a
corresponding list of elements.
And we wanted to search
among those lists.
Before I tell you
exactly what search is,
let me tell you about
the rest of the graph.
And this is, sorry, in
an ordered universe.
So it's one dimensional.
Edge is labeled with a range
from that ordered universe a,
b.
Every edge has some range.
You can think of it
as a directed graph.
It's probably cleaner.
So when I follow this
edge, there's a range here.
And, basically, I'm only
allowed to follow that edge
if the range contains the
thing I'm searching for.
So here, I was searching for
some item x in all the lists.
There's no ranges here.
But in general, you
get to specify a range.
Why do we want to
specify a range?
We need a sort of bounded
degree constraint.
We want to have
bounded n degree.
So here we had n degree
1 for every node.
In general, we
don't want to have
too many nodes pointing in.
Because we want to take
half the nodes in here,
or a constant
fraction of the items
here, and promote them into
all the nodes that point to it,
so that when we
follow the pointer,
we get to know where
we belong here.
That's the general concept.
So, ideally, we have
bounded n degree.
If we do, we're done.
We can have a slightly
weaker condition,
which is called
locally-bounded n degree where
the number of incoming edges for
a node whose labels are ranges
The labels have to have
a common intersection, x.
So we're searching
for some item x.
And if all the possible ways we
can enter this node given item
x--
so this x has to fall
in all those ranges--
that should be bounded, so,
at most, some constant c.
If it's always at
most c for all nodes
and for all x's, then this
is locally-bounded degree.
And these range labels help
you achieve this property.
If you can constrain
that you're only
going to follow this edge
in certain situations
and there aren't
too many ways you
could have gotten to a node,
then you have this property.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
bound to x?
ERIK DEMAINE: Contain x is
a backwards containment.
Let me put it this way.
You have a node.
You have all these
edges coming into it.
I want x to be a valid choice
for each of these edges.
Meaning, the range, each of them
is some interval on the line.
All those intervals
should contain x.
It's basically, if you laid
out all the intervals incoming
into this node, what
is the maximum depth
of those intervals?
What's the maximum intersection
between all those intervals?
That is your local degree.
And as long as that's the
constant, we're happy.
All right.
So now, let me specify
what a search means.
This is the problem that
fractional cascading can solve.
Goal is to find x in
some k vertex sets.
So k vertices, each
of them has a set.
I want to find x in k of them.
Not all of them, k of them.
That's the general problem.
I have a constraint on
how those sets are found.
They're found by navigating this
graph starting from any vertex.
And we navigate by following
edges whose labels contain x.
So we started some
vertex in the graph.
We can follow some
edges that contain
x. x is a valid choice here
that's inside the interval.
Then from here, maybe we
follow some more where
x is a valid choice, and so on.
It could look like anything.
It doesn't have to be depth
first or breadth first.
It's just you follow
some tree from some node
where all of the
edges are valid for x.
At some point, you decide
that I've seen enough.
And now, the goal is to find
in this set, where is x?
In this set, where is x?
In each of these lists, what
is a predecessor and successor
of x?
Question.
AUDIENCE: So there's
generally some root node
from which all queries start?
ERIK DEMAINE: I believe you do
not need a single root node.
Each search could start
from a different point.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it's [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: But
you're told where.
So imagine this is like
an interaction between two
parties.
So the input basically says,
look, I'm searching for x.
And I'm going to
start at this node.
And then the fractional
cascading data structure
says, OK, here's where
x is in that node.
It tells you immediately.
Why not?
Then it says, OK, I'd
like to follow this edge
and go to this node.
And fractional
cascading says, OK,
here's where x is in this
node in constant time.
OK.
Then now these two
guys are active.
And now, the adversary, the
input, whatever, can decide,
OK, I'm going to follow this
edge, or this edge, any order.
It can build this
tree in any order.
And every time it says here's
the edge I want to follow,
the fractional cascading data
structure in constant time
tells you here's
where x is among all
the items in that node.
How does it do that?
With fractional cascading.
You just take half the items.
Half doesn't work anymore.
Now, it depends on
that bounded n degree.
But you take some
function of that degree
c, take some constant
fraction of the items,
promote them to all
the things, keep going.
It's a little trickier,
because now you have cycles.
So you could actually
promote back into yourself,
eventually, by chain reactions.
But if you set the
constant low enough,
it's like radioactive decay.
Eventually, it all
goes away, right?
I wish.
So it's much better
than radioactive decay.
Radioactive is logarithmic.
This is exponential.
So it's decreasing very quickly.
After log n steps, all
your items are gone.
So, yeah, maybe you go in
a short loop for a while.
But after log n
steps, it's all gone.
So you're, at most,
increasing by a log factor.
In fact, you just increase
by a constant factor,
because the number
of items that remain
gets so tiny very quickly.
So I'm not going to
go into the details,
but you just take this list
idea, apply it to your graph.
It works.
It gets messier.
But in this very
general scenario,
you can support
these searches in k
plus log n where n, let's
say, is the maximum size
of any vertex set.
So just it directly generalizes.
And this is the
thing that you can
use to get this log
factor improvement
and many other things.
Actually, this was such
a big thing at the time.
There were two papers on
fractional cascading, part 1
and part 2.
Part 1 is what is solving this.
And part 2 is applications.
They solved a ton of
problems that no one
knew how to solve using this
general fractional cascading
technique.
That's it for today.